and at 4:10 a.m. on Wednesday March 13th
CNN did a 38 second newsreader on the
case noting the arrest of Carranza the
next day with Ingram angle brought you
exclusive new information that local
sanctuary policies tied to this criminal
being able to roam the streets freely
and illegally even after officials
blamed ice for their pathetic policies
now since that exclusive not one network
cable or otherwise has brought you even
a single second of amble arson story now
why is that
well here's just a snippet of stories
that they deemed more important than the
brutal murder of an American by an
illegal immigrant tonight we have an
inside look at a new vertical landmark
with its awe-inspiring views you can't
miss turning back Kareem Hunt has now
been suspended for eight games punished
by the league for a pair of physical
altercation
unlike other left-handed guitarists Dale
didn't restrain right-handed guitars he
played them upside down the media is one
thing but the officials tasked with
keeping their citizens safe is quite
another now on Friday we brought you a
list of Santa Clara elected officials
who refused to appear or offer any real
statement on the record to us and only
one of those officials responded tonight
that's James Williams the County Council
who blamed ice in his news conference he
pointed us to a statement he gave the
day before we revealed those exclusive
documents showing that County policy was
really at fault they provided no update
and no explanation well one person
demanding answers is one of Bambi
Larson's close friends Dianne Coleman
she's wondering how this guy was ever
allowed to go free and also he claimed
asylum
it claimed incredible fear when he came
into the United States set free and
she's even calling for him to get the
death penalty here now exclusively is
Dianne Coleman Diane I'm so sorry for
your loss and what you were going
through and of course Bambi's son
who undoubtedly is too grief-stricken to
speak tell me about her yes I would I
would love to tell you and first of all
thank you for having me Laura thank you
for covering this story because
everything you just said is what I've
been feeling for two and a half weeks I
would love to tell you and your audience
about my beautiful friend
Bambi Larson she was one of the kindest
gentlest classiest most decent people
that I have the honor of saying was my
friend we met as yoga students in 2004
15 years ago and then I became her
teacher and then we became friends Bambi
was a woman who was my true friend she
showed up for me in really good times in
my life and she showed up for me in
really hard times and the thing that I
feel was especially extraordinary is
that I never had to ask this woman to
show up for me she she needs me to show
up for her now if you will indulge me
I'd like to tell you a really personal
story that will give you an idea of just
who she was so I mainly taught Bambi in
a large class capacity but five years
ago my family and I moved and I had the
opportunity to have my own very small
yoga studio in my basement that my
husband built me and I will tell you
Laura
I could not beg borrow or steal to get
people to come to class and I was a
woman who had thousands of yoga studio
what did she do for you except for Bambi
Larson so Bambi Larson came to my home
studio two times every week now that's
nice enough right but she actually had
the this incredible decency to email me
and register online for every class she
took yeah and she would ask in those
emails if I might have space for Bambi
Larson yeah so she knew exactly front
yeah she's a true friend she cared she
was a true friend and it's hard to find
that but I have to ask you I have to ask
you to speak for her
if you could say one thing to these
county officials that were trying to
pass the blame sure to a government
agency had nine times requested that
this guy be held until they could pick
him up and get him processed out of the
country they never turned him over
what's your message to those local
officials tonight I'm happy to speak for
Bambi shame on you you have blood on
your hands there's no reason this
beautiful incredible human being should
have been butchered the way that she was
in her own bed in her own home
defenseless as she could be and what I
was trying to finish Laura was to tell
you that what Bambi did for me in 2014
and 2015 is she restored my dignity at a
time in my life where it had been
stripped for other reasons I am here
tonight to restore hers because she was
killed she was murdered in the most
undignified way possible and that is not
okay with me and I don't want to hear
that she has a one-off I don't want to
hear the buck being passed from one
department to the next I want people to
know this was a real person who deserved
to be safe in her own bed she was
law-abiding she was a taxpaying citizen
she was a homeowner she was a mother she
would have loved to have become a
grandmother she was incredible she was
as good as she looks in the photographs
that I've provided her she look she has
that she has that it would be yeah she
has that face you could just tell she
zigzoo's you can see in the photo you
know photos tell you she does look happy
nice person which you can see happy I
have to ask you about the sanctuary
policies that allow this kind of thing
to continue in the state of California
they should this be a blessing and are
you kidding of course and the best part
about being on your show is I want
president Trump's here and he is my
president and I'm proud to call him that
and there are good-hearted Californians
who think this is crazy
immigrant friends of mine among them who
think this is crazy
because it is people tell me that I'm
courageous to speak this is not courage
this is a right and wrong and there is
no it's
laughs and white now this is common
sense
raised by good parents Diane we're we're
we're out of time yes but we're gonna
follow this story I'm sure we're gonna
I'm sure going to have you back
Diane thank you and my message is please
President Trump I beg of you keep us
safe
this is insane and I will not stop
speaking up for bamboo bars I'm Diane
thank you much thank you